j'aime
[Applaudissements]
11 mars 2020 l'organisation mondiale de
la santé déclare la pandémie la coved 19
pouces que tout
comac l'argent va rentrer je pense que
ça commence et un gros sous
des destins brisés
[Musique]
j'ai perdu mon mari a accosté la ligne
de chasse
[Musique]
on n'a pas pu la campagne pour son
dernier voyage
des parcours renouvelé
j'ai aucune expérience voici juste leur
fait comme ça
maintenant proposer leur cité
1 en 2 j entre parenthèses
un an d'une autre les mots
bonsoir mesdames messieurs ici céline
galipeau bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale
nous sommes au théâtre denise pelletier
à montréal un théâtre magnifique mais
désertée de ses comédiens vide
à l'image d'un monde en suspens forcé de
s'arrêter il ya un an
la crise est loin d'être finie mais on
vous propose ce soir de commencer à
réfléchir ensemble pour essayer de
donner un sens à cette épreuve à
laquelle on a tous été confrontés avec
des invités comme le neuropsychiatre
boris cyrulnik mais aussi avec des
reportages des histoires inspirantes de
gens qui ont donné un nouveau souffle à
leur parcours
parce qu'il y en a eu même si on reste
marqué par les moments plus sombres
il y a eu plus de deux millions six cent
mille morts dans le monde 22 1371 ici au
pays des gens comme gilles beaulieu 87
ans qui a ouvert les yeux de sa fille
natacha aux sur la beauté de la nature
transgreen 48 ans un gentleman toujours
joyeux préposé pendant 17 ans à
l'hôpital jean-talon à montréal
nicole hoffman 20 ans intelligente
généreuse une grande fan des oilers à
edmonton
jean-paul valence 84 ans un homme bon
aimant la vie et dont les éclats de rire
provoqué la joie de vivre selon ses
proches
ghislaine si marc bellemare 82 ans une
mère adorée passionné de golf et de ski
et qui aimait fabriquer des cartes de
souhaits pour ces êtres chers
en cette journée de commémoration nous
pensons nous aussi à ces disparus et à
leurs proches
deux femmes suzanne arruda et à motifs
orale ou s'ils ont accepté de se confier
même si la douleur restent très vives
pour qu'on n'oublie pas ce qui s'est
passé
l'une n'a pas pu accompagner son père
antonio arruda dans ses derniers moments
et l'autre on vous en a déjà parlé il ya
quelques mois sans le savoir à la
contaminer son mari des airs et bouna et
vara qui est ensuite décédé de lakovic
[Musique]
c'est toujours difficile pour moi
d'aider réalisé 6 est vraiment passé
parce qu'ils aient accepté la perte et
des moments harris a été vraiment
difficile pour moi aurait lui il est
énorme près généré il aimait beaucoup
ses enfants il m'aimait beaucoup c'est
un homme qui aimait aider aussi beaucoup
de gens nous les manques au vraiment
[Rires]
et
ah non par terre c'était la joie de vie
c'était jusqu'à la fin le sourire les
blagues ont peint avec toujours une
blague
c'était l'humour c'était un sourire son
bonheur que la musique son monarque
d'avoir sa famille autour de lui ses
enfants
[Musique]
je travaille allez demain de la santé et
pendant la pandémie
notre centre d'hébergement a été
affectée alors et c'est j'ai contacté la
maladie le virus au niveau de mon
travail mais moi je ne savais pas si
j'étais malade parce que je ne
présentait pas de symptômes et quelques
jours après c'est lui qui a commencé à
me dit que non il se sent comme si c'est
le début des grippes et mon mari a
commencé à faire la difficulté
respiratoire
ces vermines pour la transférer l'otage
sur deux mois
là il est demeuré d'aller coma
artificiel l'a fait au moins quand tous
les jours dans l'est pour moi oui mon
père fred de démence depuis quelques
années où vous voulez vraiment le garder
à la maison le plus longtemps possible
le siège à celle du bassin vraiment une
solution où on n'avait pas le choix
[Musique]
c'est toujours une décision difficile
pour nous ça a été un premier 200 et et
puis pour ma mère qui n'a jamais été
séparée de son mari ne jamais en plus de
50 ans à presque 60 ans à l'autre au
jour était avec avec son oeil
ma mère qui allaient tous les jours
s'est fait dire le 12 ou le 13 mars que
les visites étaient interrompues selon
le poids revu mon ami la très très très
grande chance d'avoir une bénévole qui
qui a fait une escale avec lui on a pu
le voir sur skype qui partent évidemment
il était couché n'était pas très
conscient mais la lame bénévoles nous
disait que quand il entendait nos voix
basse et paupières bouger il y avait
quand même une réaction
[Musique]
on a réduit même rester à côté de lui
parce que quand mon mari était malade là
je voulais vraiment j'appelais les mains
c'est pour le supplier juste et de
motoriser de venir à son chevet mais
tout cela c'était pas possible même si
il était là couché mais peut-être été
écoutés mais mme lavoie
b nous écouter mais le téléphone aussi
n'étaient même pas autorisés olic à
muret de très loin je voulais qu'on
puisse mettre même les téléphones à son
oreille kg pas que je lui parle
mais même ça là les téléphones n'étaient
même pas autorisés d'encrés dallaire
chambre
[Musique]
[Rires]
et
on n'a pas pu l'accompagner pour son
dernier voyage puis même s'il n'était
plus ou moins conscient évidemment la
fin ben je pense que ce rituel la
d'accompagner une personne est important
c'est ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on a pu
donc si cette acceptation lait qui est
difficile je pense qu'on peut être en
paix avec le fait qu'ils soient partis
qui sauvent plus qui a fait son bout de
chemin mais la paix est difficile à
avoir avec la façon de ce n'est pas
ainsi qu'ils quittent semaines qu'on est
polluée à trier
quand ils m'ont appelé qu'il a fait
l'hémorragie cérébrale
je suis rentré dans sa chambre gd tenir
dans mes bras je lui ai expliqué
d'essayer de s'accrocher la passe qui
regarde moi je suis un set comment je
vais faire avec tous ses enfants et
vivre et la grossesse seul
je me sentais coupable on n'était pas
bien protégé ce suite à sac et ma
famille a été de santé des lacs au vide
je n'ai pas pu protéger ma famille qui
m'a créé des masses qui marque déjà
quitté l'hôpital et jacques de
protection là ont manqué ça je me dis
quand même au canada la dpj marij
comment on pouvait pas nous protéger
nous douvier maintenant tous ces masques
d'où viennent tous ces masques je vous
fait mal encore oui
ça a été une violence psychologique
on dirait que j'avais besoin d' excuses
ou de quelqu'un qui dit qu'ils prennent
leurs responsabilités qui dit ok ça bah
on a mal géré et maintenant retroussons
nos manches faisons quelque chose pour
les chs elle dit
[Musique]
j'ai encore beaucoup de colère sur la
façon où cette crise a été gérée sur la
façon où on elle laissait mourrir ces
personnes âgées le
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup prendre soin des autres
mais les malheurs est ambitieux j'ai
perdu mon mari comme sakho stella blick
déjà
je pense que c'est important surtout pas
oublier qu'ils ne pas passer à autre
chose quand qu'on va se remettre à vivre
un voyage et je pense que c'est un pan
d'histoire du québec qu'il faudra pas
oublier pour qu'elle serve de leçon
la petite est venus à changer la routine
dans la maison j'ai donné les preneurs
et prennent un réseau d opel elle
s'appelle désir et habitat c'est une
enquête qui avait beaucoup des rêves et
qui n'a même pas pu réaliser ce qu'il
voulait faire
les enfants n'arrêtent pas de parler de
lui même les plus jeunes à chaque fois
des mâles maman ou un papa
des fois même si je ne donne pas la
réponse directement été papa est au
siège du oui il est aussi
[Musique]
c'est tellement tragique ce qui s'est
passé pendant la première vague mélanie
vachement bon soir vous êtes professeur
de psychologie à l'université du québec
à montréal et vous menez justement une
étude sur le deuil pandémique
alors votre réaction après ces
témoignages il faut les entendre il faut
les entendre c'est nécessaire les
témoignages sont sont extrêmement
touchante sans par la tristesse qui
porte mais sont aussi troublant de
vérité
troublant de vérité parce que je pense
qu'ils sont très près de la réalité des
10500 familles qui ont perdu un proche
pendant la pandémie parce que ce deuil
il est difficile à faire parce que
comment comment faire son deuil quand on
n'a pas pu accompagner la personne qu'on
aime quand on n'a pas pu avoir des
funérailles entouré des proches
c'est brutal c'est extrêmement brutal
puis vous savez l'important quand on
fait le deuil c'est c'est d'abord de se
préparer d'accompagner quand on sait que
notre prochaine enfin une vie les landes
naturel des gens selon leur valeur selon
leur désir c'est d'être d'être auprès de
l'ot de de pouvoir la compagnie de la
manière dont le proche aurait souhaité
dans ses dernières volontés
puis il ya énormément de personnes qui
sont trouvés dans des dilemmes moraux
épouvantable c'est à dire que leur
éthique personnelle leur disait mais non
il faut être au chevet de quelqu'un
qu'on aime qui souffle mais pris dans le
fond par les mesures de santé publique
qui vont très peu le droit d'y aller en
force le droit du tout au début se sont
assouplies par la suite mais quand même
donc c'est puisqu'on voit aussi c'est
que ces émotions-là ses dilemmes la mort
où vécut en amont du deuil laisse des
traces de yandé regret la culpabilité on
le vue
chez ed
donc une des personnes qui dans le
reportage de l'amertume aussi parce
qu'un sentiment d'injustice par rapport
aux mesures de santé publique au départ
par rapport à la crise aussi que sévit
dans les ch et celle des puits quelques
moments de bonté parce que par exemple
cette femme qui avait il y avait une
bénévole qui a pu au moins tenir à un
écran pour qu'ils voient leur père que
la famille pour que la mère de suzanne
puisse voir son mari oui puis on le voit
aussi avec six ans et c'est une
expérience aussi un moment qu'elle
rapporte toujours qui lui permet elle le
soutenir son deuil ce moment là où se
fait la auquel elle s'accroche puis avec
avec raison où elle sait que son père
bouger les yeux quand il entendait sa
voix
donc c'est comme si à ce moment là ils
ont pu communiquer ils ont pu sentir la
présence l'un de l'autre
puis c'est définitivement un un instinct
qui lui permet de l traversé son deuil
avec avec la grande résilience qu'on lui
connaît et donc ce deuil pandémique
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle
maximum ce que je lis a appelé dans la
recherche parce que en fait ça apporte
plusieurs sens et c'est à la fois c'est
un deuil qui est pas un deuil comme les
autres je veux pas d'emblée le nommer
comme étant un deuil pathologique
parce qu'il est beaucoup trop tôt pour
le faire puis parce que tous les deuils
qui soit pandémique ou non sont
extrêmement individuelles y aura des
gens qui ont vécu un deuil en contexte
de pandémie qui se remettront de manière
relativement
je vous dirais normal de cette épreuve
depuis d'autres pour qui ça sera plus
difficile mais en quoi il est si
différent ce dont il est différent parce
qu'il n'a pas de repas parce que il se
fait au rythme c'est les gens en parlent
un peu comme un 2 qui consiste pas en
fait 1 2 qui a pas de début j'ai pas
vraiment fait que peu de repères
concrets on ne peuvent la dépouille on
n'a pas accompagné notre proche
plusieurs ont reçu les cendres quelques
jours plus tard on n'a pas pu non plus
commémoré on ne peut plus faire les
rituels puis les rituels ont pas besoin
d'être religieux les rituels de le
simple fait de recevoir des condoléances
de serrer dans nos bras
quelqu'un nous témoigne sa sympathie son
désir de partager ça ce français notre
souffrance avec avec lui de reconnaître
cette france là c'est tout des moments
que ce n'est pas permis non plus à poser
dessus c'était pas permis non plus donc
mais c'est des moments clés qui font en
sorte qu'on peut bien entamé le
processus de deuil
1 puis bien poursuivre ou si ce doit
être difficile aussi parce qu'on a
beaucoup entendu pendant cette première
vague mais de toute façon c'était des
personnes âgées qui souffrait déjà et
qui se seraient morts de toute façon il
n'y avait pas cette reconnaissance non
plus un terrible manque de
reconnaissance sociale encore plus que
ça moi je parle même d'une certaine
banalisation du deuil et à ce moment là
vous savez oui peut-être que certaines
personnes en étaient à la toute fin de
leur vie mais la manière dont on dessert
puis manama à roudet nous dit très bien
c'est très important
c'est très important la manière dont on
décède c'est très important pour les
proches c'est très important pour la
personne puis puis puis une manière
digne est belle de faire les choses
c'est un passage l'existence qui mérite
d'être accompagné donc ça c'est oui
c'est tout à fait tu respires tellement
eu de deux et ça c'est l'autre
signification du deuil pandémique une
pandémie de deuil en 1500 morts on parle
de plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes en deuil
les disques h sur un peu derrière les
chiffres
on leur a donné des statistiques on
accepte donc puis ça donne tout son sens
à ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui en fait de
pouvoir voir derrière ces chiffres là
les vies qui ont été transformés puis
les tragédies ou c'est qu'ils ont été
vécus et donc cette journée de
commémoration nationale aujourd'hui
c'est important pour les familles
extrêmement important d'abord c'est une
première reconnaissance j'ai regardé la
cérémonie aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
émouvant
peut-être très émouvante je pense que ça
a eu un effet apaisant sur plusieurs
personnes d'une petite danger assaut il
y aurait peut-être un petit écueil se
serait de penser que parce qu'on
commémore ou que comme et maurice d'une
fin en soi c'est pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui on on a cette journée
leur dans laquelle on prend conscience
de ce qui s'est passé que hic le reste
du temps passe à autre chose ou qu'on ne
rebondit pas de cette épreuve le ou
qu'on l'utilisent pas pour entamer une
réflexion profonde sur la manière dont
on aborde la vieillesse la fin de vie le
2 la mort collectivement socialement
politiquement parce qu'un immense défi
qui nous attend près la covin un défi à
long terme c'est de vieillissement de la
population et mieux traiter nos
personnes âgées et repenser parce qu'on
on pour repenser la manière dont on fait
les choses faut penser plutôt un terme à
mon sens de soutien domicile le québec
est le deuxième endroit dans le monde où
glissement de la population est le plus
rapide le premier temps japon a déjà ils
ont commencé à s'organiser là-bas pour
aborder ça donc je pense qu'on une
il faut se servir de cette expérience là
de la pandémie
puis donner un sens à voudrais aussi
dire en faire quelque chose vient créer
une opportunité d'apprendre stage pour
se préparer au prochain défi qu'on leur
collectif à l'image ans est un défi
énorme mais il faut prioriser nos
personnes âgées absolument merci
beaucoup
vous merci en attendant on commence
malgré tout avoir un peu la lumière au
bout du tunnel vous le savez avec la
vaccination qui s'accélère et en a
justement voulu prendre des nouvelles de
ses aînés qu'on a assez peu entendu
pendant la pandémie
on leur a demandé ce qu'ils allaient
retenir de cette crise une fois que tout
cela sera fini on les écoute
c'est ce que j'aime avec une bâche des
eaux
mais pour meurtre à mon goût mais la
neige pour nous avions noté que vous
allez retenir quoi cependant il faut
faire attention en autriche à propos de
notre squelette par des migrants à voir
avec les c'est que jusqu'à quel point on
était libres avant sara lee
mais on ne s'en apercevait qu on voit
davantage l'importance de mettre en
essence les ventes à faire c'est
pourquoi moi ça m'a appelé à la lente et
je vous ralentit la mise actifs
moi j'ai rien dis que la vie malgré tout
de la peine d'être vécue il faut croquer
dans chaque moment qu'ils s'offrent à
nous et en profiter pleinement
mais seuls primo mer ici au village sans
mon appel révèle chrome et c'est pour ça
qu'on reste impensable qu'on était une
remise haute
ça nous aurait approché encore plus avec
bon goût globe awards afin de louer ou
marc thibault go
moi ce que je retiens de la pandémie
c'est le mans de cannes un de mes
enfants de mes petits endroits et
surtout de montmagny qui aurait placé
que voulait toujours respecté le 2 mai
de la première chose que toi à saidal et
moi une personne ne demande jamais seul
van gogh à ce que c'est ça j'ai personne
extérieure bénéficie la france
gd ailleurs enfin que je n'ai pas vu
depuis une heure oui oui je pourrais me
séduit des privés de sorte d'ange tous
les terrains on s'est ennuyé tout ça
mais d'un autre côté berne ont été
protégés ce qui m'a plus marqué pas mal
à paris moi ça fait de la levure j'ai
été épargné moi et mon entourage ou
c'est par la coved et nous savons que
c'est grâce aux efforts incroyables de
courage d'audace de créativité de tant
de gens qui ont pris soin de nous qui
ont été renflouées par vous voyez on
offre donnerait on est même devenu bon
soyons optimistes
et n'oublions pas dans la vie tout passe
on a compris plus que depuis longtemps
l'importance de s'occuper les uns des
autres
quand tu es un masque c'est s'occuper de
l'autre évitez les espérances et
s'occuper de l'autre et pour l'avenir
j'ai confiance à nos artistes éclaireur
pour nous de rappeler
oui les artistes des éclaireurs comme le
dit si bien madame pelletier alors pour
rendre hommage aux victimes
voici une version toute particulière
d'une grande chanson québécoise
[Musique]
où
on ne choisit pas toujours la route
li même moment du départ
on n'efface pas toujours le doute
[Musique]
la vieille peur d'être en retard
et la vie
c'est fragile
[Musique]
on choisit jamais de vieillir
on voudrait rêver un peu plus
[Musique]
la vie n'est pas faite pour mourir
on meurt souvent bien entendu car
[Musique]
et c'est vrai j
si fragile
est si fragile
un pôle un teint auto tma
[Musique]
demain
pour notre mine clients
m
et mécary de rien
mourinho j'y touche incombent
[Musique]
sanou ppc s'ennuyait
non pas tous à nous quatre
[Musique]
non
et l'ayant kaboré pour bon pied
c'est pin façon janvier malaise passe la
vie fragile confie
et si fragile
[Musique]
si fragile
et si fragile le temps est là
jour la seule justice ici bas
on déchiffre agir
on marche sur l'eau sur l'art j
dépend de ce qu'on m'a reçu
[Musique]
mais on reste tout aussi fragile
pourquoi donc se marcher dessus
car elle vit
[Musique]
carey vie
b si fragile dynamo
est si fragile
j d'oujda est issu
tous droits
[Musique]
merci c'était magnifique
luc de larochellière malika tirolien et
florent vollant
après la pause des destins changé dans
le réseau de la santé et des femmes
inspirantes à new york
[Musique]
e
il y a les victimes leurs proches mais
aussi tous ceux qui sont nos héros
depuis un an
les travailleurs de la santé qui sont
encore au front tous les jours contre
lacko vide et on les remercie du fond du
coeur
une mission difficile exigeante qui en a
amené certains à revoir leurs priorités
leurs plans de vie entre autres pour
mieux prendre soin des plus vulnérables
sophie langlois parce que le sérieux est
déjà là et vous croquer dans ce temps-là
s'apparent ait pu lui fera les démarches
à pour venir vous voir comme ça tout va
bien
comment allez vous j'étais content de
voir puisque les risques des grands pas
me le dise il savait lui-même centre ont
eu du courage de prendre son alignement
qu'on le virus l'infirmière a connu un
résident qui l'a soignée lors de la
dernière éclosion
elle venait de prendre sa retraite quand
la pandémie est débarqué dans les 6 h et
celle des poc tout à l'heure la partir
en laissant des gens malades qui vont
mourir jeune homme je ne crois pas je
pense que j'aurais pas survécu à sa
bernadette valmiera a pris soin des
aînés pendant 37 ans je suis habitué à
voir a côtoyé la mort mais pas la mort
aussi sauvé par l'amour aussi nombreuses
vous avez comme les pressions que vous
avez bien tous les jours qui vous donner
des soins bonne meuf elle un bonjour
bonjour
vous devez y tout de même pas plus belle
bravo
l'urgentologue n'est pas un habitué des
ch et celle d il les a découverts durant
la première vague quand elle a vu les
malades de la coved cordée dans une
grande salle commune
il a eu un choc déjà ils avaient leur
petite chambre et puis la non même puis
sont tous ensemble pêle-mêle sans aucune
intimité
ça m'a beaucoup à vous lever resservir
mais c'était franchement c'était
vraiment comme les entasser ça va
paraître un peu morbide ce que je dis
mais vraiment je n'arrêtais pas de
penser à ça c'est vraiment con les
entasser dans les cages aux bestiaux
comme dans certaines moment de notre
histoire
cette vision le honte il réfléchit au
sort des aînés dans nos sociétés
modernes
il décide de prendre un virage quand
j'ai vu ça je dis non c'est pas possible
il faut que les gens restent chez eux
autant que possible et puis pour que ça
soit fait il faut qu'ils aient des
équipes qui s'occupent de la maison et
le médecin en fait partie petit parti
ceci dit petit parti fait que c'est pour
ça que là j'ai décidé plutôt d'aller en
soins à domicile savait que sylvain
aujourd'hui n'est pas là il a été obligé
de s'absenter
les absents sont un cauchemar pour les
gestionnaires comme bernadette si pour
cela qu'elle est revenue à aider
plusieurs fois depuis un an
je ne crois pas que les gens imaginent
qu est-ce que c'est de manquer de
personnel pour donner des soins aux
malades
je ne crois pas vous savez ça ça ça
c'est vraiment c'est une souffrance
atroce ça
l'infirmière prend à nouveau sa retraite
le 29 décembre dernier
mais le 8 janvier il est encore appelée
en renfort
habituellement c'est son mari qui
conduit bernadette au travail mais il a
failli mourir de l'aco vide en octobre
et il est encore trop faible pour
travailler je me souvenais pas du nom de
mes enfants de mon épouse monsieur
jacques qui enseigne au secondaire
introduit lakovic et lui il a contaminé
sa femme et leurs deux grands enfants
malgré les séquelles il les risques il a
encouragé bernadette retourner au front
en janvier car il sait à quel point ça
peut sauver des vies
on a dit que c'est pas le temps
d'abandonner celle là c'est là qu'il
faut aller b les autres ceux qui sont
dans le besoin
ja prévoit terminer 10ème semaine des
mais c'est pas vrai c'est pas mal du
tout quand vous appelle et sera la
première oui
il est 6 h et celle des gens de la lande
a été très durement frappée depuis un an
90 décès liés à la coved soit le tiers
des résidents étrangers vers la pandémie
a permis à l'urgentologue de reconnecter
avec l'autre dimension de la médecine
juste le fait d'aller les voir discuter
déjà et déjà fait une présence d'abord
puisque par le temps qui courent il n'y
a pas grand présence et puis il y confie
juste ça c'est bénéfique
les baies pilule le médical c'est gentil
mais c'est pas l'essence 1,2 des soins
les soins si c'est s'occuper mais et
mais quoi le médecin fait encore un peu
d'urgence en région éloignée le temps de
développer sa pratique de soins à
domicile pour éviter à trop d'aînés
d'aller au ch et celle des sens les
dénigrer on vraiment que c'est maximiser
les options pour pouvoir rester à
domicile et aider en particulier les
aidants
et cette pandémie a transformé que je
n'ai plus peur de la mort oui je fais
attention
d'accord je ne suis pas suicidé mais si
jamais je meurs avec la ville pendant
que je travaille
dites vous que je suis moi heureuse pour
[Musique]
quelle force quel courage quelle
témoignages deux témoignages très très
fort et qui soulève toutes sortes de
questions alors avec moi ce soir
françoise david scène députés de
l'assemblée nationale et ancien
président de la fédération des femmes du
québec bonsoir france pour soi et
dorothy rhau qui elle dirige un
organisme audace au féminin qui aide les
femmes noires à prendre leur place dans
notre société tout à fait bonsoir de
recrutement soir d'abord quand on voit
des femmes comme bernadette on se
demande comment comment ça se fait qu'il
ya autant de ces femmes haïtiennes qui
s'occupe des soins ici à montréal
quand on vous un an vous injecte une
dose de générosité de courage de force à
la naissance mais je pense aussi que ça
fait partie de nos valeurs de s'occuper
entre autres deux des membres de la
famille des personnes âgées
j'aime souvent dire que dans chaque
famille haïtienne il ya des personnes
âgées qui sont un peu nous bibelots
exactement donc on a grandi avec nos
grands parents et c'est tout à fait
normal de s'occuper d'eux et qu'on voit
nos parents qui ont fait ce geste mais
même nous une fois devenu adulte c'est
normal de reproduire ce même geste là
auprès de nos parents qui vise donc je
pense qu'à la base c'est une valeur
qu'on retrouve dans certaines
communautés culturelles
et oui très très très présents eux dans
la communauté haïtienne parce qu'on
regarde au niveau dans les réseaux de la
santé mam sur trois est une femme noire
est dans la com de taye c'est une femme
sur deux quand même moi dans ma famille
je ne je n'arrive pas compter que ce
soit y serment real oublier à l'étranger
aux états unis beaucoup de membres de ma
famille sont dans les soins de la santé
et les femmes les femmes mangent ni
femme noire mais pas seulement les
femmes ont joué un rôle essentiel
françoise dans cette crise
au fond on peut dire que sans elle on
aurait peut-être pas traverser la
tempête de la même façon écoutez c'est
assez simple puis en même temps un peu
dramatique pour toutes sortes de raisons
au québec
neuf emplois sur dix dans les services
publics communautaires parapublic privé
sont occupés par des femmes
c'est aussi simple que ça
sans les femmes québécoises de toutes
origines
il n'y a pas de service public il n'y a
pas de services sociaux il n'y a pas
d'action communautaire
alors évidemment ça veut dire que durant
la pandémie toutes ces femmes et des
hommes aussi évidemment on travaillait
dirai rien sur remarquable ils ont très
long travail et du raison travaillé fort
dans la santé dans l'éducation dans les
services sociaux dans les services de
garde et ne l'oublions pas le premier
ministre l'a rappelé midi et c'était
bien dans les épiceries dans les
magasins jugés essentiels beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes encore tous ces
petits métiers dont on appris on a pris
conscience tout à coup du rôle essentiel
qu'il jouait dans nos vies on a pris
conscience de ce rôle et j'espère qu'on
a pris conscience du fait que très
souvent les femmes assument ces rôles
avec des salaires des revenus avec des
conditions de travail qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les conditions de travail qu
occupe beaucoup beaucoup de monsieur
beaucoup de gars dans les mines dans les
forêts dans la construction
l'infirmière bachelière gagne la moitié
du salaire du jeune homme qui sent
retravaillé dans une mine
j'espère que ça aussi on l'a compris
parce que sinon le problème c'est que
toutes ces femmes remarquables on a nos
vues n'y en a des milliers des dizaines
de milliers c'est comme si elle devait
se contenter de se faire dire merci de
se faire féliciter de se faire donner
une belle tape sur l'épaule alors que
leur travail vaut plus
et vaut mieux j'espère que la pandémie
nous aura permis de comprendre si on a
même parlé d'elle en dix ans étaient des
anges gardiens comment ça a été reçue
bien oui c'est sûr comme disait madame
david de ce sont des compléments des
félicitations c'est maintenant qu'on
considère qu on voit leurs valeurs dans
la société québécoise ces femmes qui
sont les réseaux de la santé mais aussi
qu'ils sont lancinants qui occupe
beaucoup de place dans tout ce qui est
les postes est essentielle mais est-ce
qu'on valorise leurs connaissances en
fait de conditions de vie conditions de
travail alors mention de santé ou si on
les a bien protégé
appel aux anges gardiens mais on a vu ce
témoignage exactement parce qu'on voit
malheureusement que les espy soeur
épicentre de certaines villes c'est
montréal ont été affectés en pense on
pense à montréal-nord on pense à
saint-michel et dans ces villes en fait
il ya beaucoup de communautés racisées
donc qu'est ce qui a été fait pour
protéger ces femmes là et on parle aussi
des deux demanderesses d'asile dans leur
station est toujours précaire et qui
n'ont pas nécessairement accès à des
garderies subventionnées
donc c'est tout c'est juste ces enjeux
là qui fait que la tâche est lourde sans
compter aussi qu'elle a et à la tâche
les tâches ménagères
il ya jongler avec tout ce travail dont
on ne parle pas et qu'elles font quand
même nos héros et qu'elles font et la
charge émotionnelle
il ya des tabous ci qui existe a encore
plus dans nos communautés culturelles
qui ont pendant de santé mentale donc
pour nous c'est encore nous on sait pas
vraiment à qui s'adresser il manque de
personnel aussi pour traiter ces bons au
niveau de la santé mentale donc oui
c'est bien qu'on puisse les considérer
les voir comme des anges garde qu on les
félicite
mais je pense qu'il faut passer à des
actions beaucoup plus concrète qui va
améliorer leur vie leur statut précaire
parce que c'est aussi les femmes qui ont
été le plus touchées en termes d'emploi
de pertes d'emplois pendant toute cette
endémie france clairement les
statistiques sont très éloquente la
majorité des emplois perdus et qu'ils le
sont encore ont été des emplois féminins
il ya aussi des femmes qui ont quitté
leur emploi
on pense aussi à des femmes par exemple
comme les infirmières dans le secteur
public qui sont allés travailler pour
des agences privées non pas pour
améliorer leurs salaires mais pour
améliorer leurs conditions de travail
pour avoir un petit peu plus un choix
d'horaires
parce que travailler 16 heures par jour
plusieurs jours par semaine ça n'a aucun
sens on pourrait parler des violences
faites aux femmes de retire parler de la
détresse psychologique donc tout un
ensemble de facteurs qui font que oui
tout le monde a payé cher durant cette
pandémie
mais les femmes plus que d'autres alors
je me dis aujourd'hui que si l'on veut
reconnaître tout ce travail que les
femmes ont accompli accomplissent encore
y compris dans leurs familles d'ailleurs
je suis allé pour m'amuser un peu dans
le dictionnaire regarder ce que voulait
dire le mot reconnaître ce mot il a
toutes sortes de signification mais il y
en a une qui m'a frappé c'est avoir de
la gratitude et avoir de la gratitude
maintenant pour moi ça veut dire oui
augmenter le personnel dans l'ensemble
des services qu'on connaît rémunérer le
travail des femmes à sa juste valeur et
cesser de parler de relance économique
uniquement par des mots comme mean forêt
construction il faut donner un peu d'âme
à l'économie et l'âme d'un peuple l'âme
d'une nation tient dirait le premier
ministre legault ce sont les liens entre
les gens se sont beaucoup les personnes
qui s'occupent des autres les personnes
qui s'occupent des communautés et parmi
ces personnes on retrouve une majorité
de femmes
donc la relance économique doit être
féministe où elle ne sera pas oui vous
reconnais bien là françoise mais c'est
pas seulement on parle du québec on
parle du canada mais c'est vraiment une
situation qu'on retrouve ce recul un
défendre pendant la pandémie un peu
partout dans le monde
d'ailleurs je voulais vous montrer des
chiffres qui sont qui donne vraiment
froid dans le dos il ya 47 millions de
femmes et de filles de plus dans le
monde qui vivent maintenant sous le
seuil de la pauvreté
donc avec 2 3 dollars par jour et il ya
il y aurait jusqu'à 20 millions de
filles des jeunes filles des jeunes
femmes qui ne retourneront jamais à
l'école parce que pendant cette pandémie
beaucoup ont été les écoles ont été
fermées les qu'il y avait plus de
couilles avec plus de classe elles ont
été mariées où elles ont elles ont eu
des enfants donc cédé recul extrêmement
important pour les femmes oui absolument
et c'est pour ça que c'est le moment
présentement de pouvoir repenser à des
plans d actions des politiques qui vont
favoriser l'insertion bien la place des
femmes dans la société québécoise pour
nous faire en sorte que dans dix ans
lorsqu'il y aura une autre crise que nos
droits nous trois ne soit pas encore mis
de côté qu'on ne puisse pas régresser en
regarde au niveau de la relance
économique comme
mentionnée mais aussi est-ce qu'on fait
partie de ces tables décisionnaires et
ça dans toutes les sphères que ce sont
les mots changent
comment on change de mentalité là ça
commence par la direction ça commence en
politique ça commença à insérer ces
femmes là mais là aussi leur donner un
pouvoir et qu'elle soit vraiment en
place parce qu'une femme peut-être elle
n'a pas atteint ses objectifs qu'elle
doit tout de suite être éjecté de son
siège
non au contraire qu'on puisse avoir une
équipe autour de ça mais c'est important
d'avoir des fans et moi c'est sûr que je
veux toujours parlé aussi au nom des
femmes racisées c'est important de les
avoir autour des tables décisionnel
aussi pour que toute la société
québécoise puisse en bénéficient et non
un pont bien segment de la population
donc une leçon à tirer du tout ça
françois en terminant bah je vais le
répéter mais c'est même de l'âme dans
une société comprendre que le bonheur
d'un peuple c'est pas seulement les
emplois dans l'industrie numérique
mettons ce important j'en conviens mais
c'est de penser une fois pour toutes que
les services qu'on se donne les services
qu'on se rend les uns aux autres les
unes aux autres c'est tout aussi
important
ces services là ce sont les femmes qui
les donnent de manière générale il faut
avoir de la gratitude et que cette
gratitude s'exprimant ce geste
françoise david retiro merci beaucoup
d'éclairage merci d'avoir été là
heureusement tout n'est pas négatif
quand même voici maintenant des femmes
qui elles ont décidé de ne pas attendre
la reprise et ont décidé de lancer leur
propre entreprise
notre correspondant raphaël bouvier au
clair les a rencontrés à new york
le coeur économique des etats-unis
barreau ralenti
[Musique]
dans cette ville où taux de chômage
demeure plus élevé qu'ailleurs au pays
des femmes ont choisi d'avancer à contre
courant le confinement du prétend venait
à peine d'être annoncée quant à me casse
krivine a choisi de plonger employés
d'une entreprise technologique
elle a lancé sa boutique virtuelle de
vente de perruques un rêve qu'elle
caressait depuis des années ce qui l'a
convaincu le sort réservé à sa mère qui
a perdu son emploi dans un hôtel après
vingt ans de loyaux services
le pari était risqué mais les clientes
ont répondu à l'appel
tadic a su profiter de la fermeture des
salons de coiffure considérés comme non
essentiels
la jeune femme n'est pas la seule à
avoir opté pour un changement malgré les
millions perte d'emploi la création
d'entreprises aux etats-unis a connu une
forte augmentation pendant la pandémie
ou troisième trimestre de 2020 les
demandes de permis étaient en hausse de
80% par rapport à l'année précédente
parmi ces entreprises qui ont vu le jour
l'épicerie de myriam saint pierre qui a
ouvert ses portes en avril ou chaumet de
la première vague commerce est
essentielle
son magasin est installé au coeur d'un
quartier plutôt défavorisés un petit
oasis offrant des produits santé dans un
désert alimentaire ou les impacts
économiques de la pandémie pourrait
perdurer dans un contexte hors du commun
les défis ont été nombreux de
l'approvisionnement en aliments à la
conciliation travail-famille pour cette
mère de deux jeunes enfants s'occupent
des enfants notamment avec justement les
écoles qui étaient fermés et à new york
donc elles sont toujours fermées pour
une bonne partie donc s'occuper des
enfants le foyer et j'en ai vu beaucoup
souffrir de sa valérie-anne 2010 est à
la tête d'une communauté de femmes
entrepreneures expatriés à new york
un réseau qui s'est élargie avec le
virage numérique est posée par la
pandémie
à son avis inventivité et solidarité ont
aider ses membres à affronter une crise
dont elles ont durement subi les
conséquences
le fait de s'en rendre compte de le voir
encore une fois de pleine face ça permet
peut-être aussi de travailler davantage
sur certaines choses et enfin d'arriver
à
plus d'égalité
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire et économique n'est
pas terminée mais tu as me casse krivine
pense déjà à la suite des choses
la création d'une vraie boutique avec
pignon sur rue à new york puis
éventuellement en californie et en
géorgie imagine déjà ses perruques sur
la tête de clientes dans différentes
régions du pays
comme quoi il n'ya pas que le deuil et
le chômage que la pandémie laissera en
héritage
[Musique]
c'est sûr que moi la danse je suis fait
pour ça l'étain a certain age la
dernière chance
[Musique]
je vais mettre ma carrière de côté la
pandémie ça m'a permis d'aller ailleurs
de d'accepter ce changement
[Musique]
salut je m'appelle malik a dû être utile
en saskatchewan et givet et la chance de
sceller prymack radiation a causé la
cuisine doit l'apprendre imminent
malheureusement pu avoir deux bals
traditionnels ensemble avec nos amis
mais nous avons profité d'une journée
dehors où on a mis nos avis de balle et
on a été prendre des photos qu'on semble
ça m'a fait beaucoup de peine de ne pas
pouvoir voir mes amis et d'avoir ma
dernière année d'école secondaire sans
activité là que veut vraiment changer
mes plans pour diminuer
j'ai pas pu aller un bal de graduation
et on à annuler mon voyage humanitaire à
vos envies qui fait trois ans qu'ils
génèrent je voulais aller ça va une
semaine avant le départ on voyage
définissant kim aurait envoyé au
guatemala a été annulé vous allez ont
visité du vote on a dit jouan moment
juste que j moquer du confinement ducobu
19,7 m a fait de vainqueur
j'avais planifié de sortir pour la
première fois du canada
on s'attendait à passer le faire dès 18h
au restaurant avec des amis finalement
on le basée en attendant des claques
sont toute la journée parce que nous
avons pas a admis ne pas faire ton aaron
a raison klaxonner face dès 18h et on
est juste devant vos amis par
fiscalement à la fin j'ai rester ici
dans mon appartement avec ma coloc puis
on a mangé un gâteau aux carottes en
bois que j'ai fait moins
les jeunes ont souffert ils ont manqué
des moments importants pour eux cette
année des moments charnières pour se
rassembler les artistes aussi s'ennuie
des rassemblements et des spectacles
parce que du jour au lendemain
la plupart ont cessé de vivre de leur
art de leur musique mode montambault
rencontré serge brideau le chanteur
flamboyant du groupe acadien
les hôtesses d'hilaire qui a mis sa
carrière en veilleuse pour retourner à
ses anciennes amours
[Musique]
julie
cachant bilan c gepa centre du h1n1 du
strass tiges et comment cet ambulancier
en 2000 sur gvt utile pour la première
fois aussi quelqu'un qu'on se préparait
pour tout cela que l'on au virus qui
s'en vient le monde caché trop de
capitaux est quand même y'a rien là je
m'ai fait une drôle parce qu'on parte en
tournée au mois de mars nous on avait de
damas 2020 à décembre 2020 on avait des
spectacles toute l'année puis à jamais
marqués pour crever 19 tours hangzhou
sur un sur un poster
amusé classant dans mon corps ce pilote
automatique
[Musique]
l'érotisme
je suis un un acadien fier acadien de 40
ans qui est maintenant proposé aux soins
depuis le début du coc vide ça me
tentait pas de regarder le plafond qui
attendent que ça redevienne normal y est
comme un switch c'est vraiment fit
danser jour qui vengera y travailler si
j'ai fait 16 en ambulance qu'est-ce que
je peux faire
quand ces musiciens des campagnes à
garder ton ombre et tout le temps il ya
beaucoup de choses que ce qu'on va pas
la tête à ça quand je vais en fermant
les soins que j'ai vu la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
sa masse et se maquillent com - avant
que je travaille un foyer je pense que
la population est pas au courant à quel
point qu' on est à la veille d'un
tsunami gris au nouveau brunswick que
que je 6 2 3 en soirée l'armée qui va
entrer ou la cour rouge pour entrer dans
les foyers
on y lol on est juste à la veille que
tout s'écroule
je travaillais iaea des pianos un peu
partout dans le foyer pire il ya
monsieur j'ai joué avec brio puis de
piste en lui
des fois qu'il me voit elle une pointe
où il sourit tout le temps
e
puis d'avoir des gens on alzheimer qui
est âgée la musique qui tape du pied
aucun sourire des gens qui sont vraiment
plus au regard de la plafond longueur de
journée peu dingue mini réaction à ce
rythme je pense que je vais aller en
nursing j'ai fait un nom je m'inscrire à
l'université pour faire mon bac
dans la section vip
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avoir 40 ans dans la quarantaine ça fait
réfléchir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
serge brideau il a l'intention lui de
partager son temps entre ses deux
carrières mais bien d'autres musiciens
songes ou ont déjà dû abandonner la
musique
alors vous le connaissez je reçois
maintenant il est avec nous et ces gains
le chef de l'orchestré métropolitain
maestro bonsoir bonsoir c'est pas tout à
fait votre genre de musique j'imagine
mais quand même la bonne musique des
bons artistes
ça fait partie de la même famille alors
oui j'ai des goûts éclectiques
eh bien on se disait qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'artistes donc avait dû
peut-être ou qui songe à abandonner leur
carrière dans la musique parce que on
l'a la guilde je crois a fait un sondage
et qui disait que plus de la moitié
songes ou envisagent de laisser tomber
il y en a près 20% qui ont déjà décidé
de quitter c'est dramatique c'est
dramatique en fait c'est que une crise
comme celle qu'on vient de vivre ben on
est encore dedans mais les douze
derniers mois ça ça nous met encore en
face la fragilité de notre milieu
culturel la fragilité des artistes on a
une aide au québec ici qui est très
appréciable et il faut être
reconnaissant il faut savoir être
reconnaissant quand on compare à
d'autres pays mais c'était delà elle va
plus souvent aux institutions et les
institutions près leurs artistes c'est
sûr alors des gens comme un orchestre
métropolitain on est choyé meilleur un
écosystème montorio des artistes pigiste
il ya des artisans il ya des gens qui
travaillent dans les festivals l'été etc
c'est des années s'est déteint c'est une
richesse culturelle c'est un patrimoine
de gens qui ont des spécialités qui sont
formés et que c'est un effet
d'entraînement incroyable ce qui vient
de se passer et c'est ce qui m'a
inquiété mois depuis le début et qui m'a
motivé à travailler comme je lé fais
pour essayer à ma propre façon mais
comme bien d'autres d'essayer de garder
ça en vie le plus possible parce que
vous avez travaillé beaucoup finalement
pendant la pandémie va rester créatifs
sont générés
en fait comme quand on est un directeur
artistique quand on est un chef on est
comme une locomotive donc derrière soi
il ya plein de wagons et qui si moi je
mets pas l'épaule à la roue avec mes
équipes je suis pas tout seul évidemment
la superbe équipe du métropolitain mais
d'autres institutions aussi c'est pour
faire travailler les gens autour et
profiter du maximum des opportunités
qu'on nous a donnée dans les lieux
culturels ici au québec qui étaient bien
meilleures qu'ailleurs mais justement
vous venez de dire par le numérique pour
essayer de donner l'argent de l'argent
aux gens mais aussi puis j'écoutais dans
cette magnifique émission on parle
beaucoup des services et la musique
l'art le théâtre la littérature c'est un
service alors on se mettra pas à faire
le débat sur l'essentiel fanon j'oserais
pas dire qu'on est essentielle comme
quelqu'un qui fait donne des soins en
fin de vie des internes où les musiciens
sont tellement essentiel on n'a jamais
réalisé autant que il nous manquait vous
vous dites comme ça on voit cette
magnifique salle ici la salle vide ça ça
vient nous chercher parce que c'est
c'est ce qui nous manque pour que la
reste en vie mais en attendant ce qu'on
a fait c'est d'essayer de donner du
réconfort aux gens durant cette période
trouble de donner du réconfort que ce
soit en allant jouer dans l'essai chez
celles d où un même tout un chacun dans
sa quarantaine finalement si on avait
dit dans la quarantaine pendant
votre confinement vous êtes privés aussi
d'écouter la musique de regarder la
télévision d'avoir des scieries de lire
des romans donc dans ce sens là oui
c'est essentiel mais tout ça ça ne vit
qu'à cause des artistes et ça parfois
peut-être qu'on oublie ça prend des gens
derrière tout ça tout c'est tout ce
qu'on voit qui est même numérique ça
prend ça prend des gens il faut les
nourrir ces gens les folies les cultiver
en fait mais ça vous pensez que le
numérique savoir rester parce que
c'était quand même difficile son public
pour les artistes d'origine c'est très
difficile mais le numérique plus rester
et peut vivre seulement si leur vivant
reste c'est à dire que le contact avec
le public le fait de de performer
d'échangés ce moment magique qui a dans
une salle où que dans même dans un
cinéma quand on se met ensemble et qu'on
vit les mêmes émotions mais que dans une
salle de concert une interaction qui est
loch
qui est irremplaçable et que le
numérique peut pas remplacer mais le
numérique
et ça ça a été une bonne chose a pu nous
aider à développer un outil de plus et
d'ailleurs on était du je trouve en tout
cas nos musiques classiques on était du
de pouvoir explorer ce médium pour
rejoindre un public qui vient pas
normalement dans nos salles et on s'est
rendu compte avec nos présentations en
tout cas leur caisse métropolitaine ont
rejoint un nouveau public avec nos
présentations numérique on a bien
l'intention de les garder mais ça ne
peut pas alors que numérique c'est pas
la même magie et surtout le numérique
peut exister seulement si on est
ensemble mais on attend tous on espère
tous qu'on va pouvoir retourner voir des
concerts des spectacles du théâtre
mais est-ce qu'on va reprendre comme
c'était avant d'après vous où le
numérique a changé un peu les choses
mais qu'est ce qui va changer est ce que
le monde devise arts de la scène va être
le même je ne pense pas que le numérique
est l'ennemi pour reprendre comme
c'était en fait y'a pas d'ennemis je
pense que moi j'ai bon c'est sûr que je
suis d'une nature optimiste mais ce que
je crois et je sens l'envi du public de
revenir dans les salles
c'est sûr qu'ils auront une période de
crainte je vais l'appeler le crescendo
l'on est prêt n'a été pianissimo trop
longtemps j'attends le crescendo pour
qu'on puisse rejoindre retrouver le
public mais ce qui va changer
j'espère pour le mieux c'est par exemple
ce qui est arrivé dans nos
programmations
on a dû les détruire ses programmations
parce que tout s'est écroulé d'un jour à
l'autre il ya un an et en reprogrammant
ça nous a donné l'opportunité d'ouvrir
et d'accélérer des conversations bien
nécessaire
j'ai envie même de dire qui était qui
aurait dû se passer depuis longtemps
quant à la diversité de nos
programmations représentativité à
l'inclusion on prend qui se font aussi
entre les formes d'art c'est ce qui me
motive les pompes à limur d'avoir des
collaborations entre le théâtre et les
orchestres les collaborations entre un
street artiste de rue et le numéro rist
d'avoir des collaborations comme ça
inter culturel et ça je pense que ça va
rester et je souhaite qu'on retourne
plus en arrière dans cette espèce de
productivité à tout prix il faut
produire tant de représentations de
théâtre parce qu'on doit et l'harmoniser
une pression semaine pression puis la
routine s'installe alors là il y en a
plus de routine et on a vu ce qu'on a
perdu et je pense qu'on est peut-être je
souhaite en tout cas le chic pour moi
j'ai eu l'impression que ça m'a permis
de me recentrer de revenir à l'essentiel
2 pourquoi l'art besoin de le coeur de
leur a besoin de battre et c'est pour
refléter qui on est et pouvoir se parler
échanger et être un miroir de qui on est
d'être le miroir de l'autre aussi
et d'avoir cette inclusion là c'est
vraiment ce que je nous souhaite à
beaucoup d'artistes qui ont dit qu'ils
s'étaient sentis va vous voulez pas trop
en parler mais qui se sont senti un peu
exclu en disant on n'a pas été considéré
comme le travail essentiel mais
qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir faire pour
que justement nos artistes avaient parlé
de leur précarité qu'on a vu pendant
cette crise qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir
faire pour justement qu'il devienne plus
essentielles ces articles
mais d'abord je dirais que le statut de
l'artiste
c'est quand même un débat qu'on a dans
notre société depuis quelques temps et
c'est quelque chose qui existe plus en
europe
en fait c'est sûr que si on se compare
aux voisins du sud et moi en étant
responsable aussi bah oui du maître et
de philadephie ce beaucoup beaucoup plus
difficile cette précarité est encore
plus cruel je dirais mais en europe il
existe quand même des façons de
considérer l'artiste comme un certain
statut c'est à dire une façon de payer
l'artiste pour qu'ils puissent vivre
aussi de son art puisse créer alors le
plein de programmes on est presque là je
trouve au québec mais on n'a pas encore
trouvé un moyen de rejoindre et de
s'assurer de la pérennité des artistes
parce que l'exemple et l'analogie que
j'aime donner moi c'est par rapport à
l'édifice mme société neutre
la société combattit et dont on est fier
malgré ses défauts c'est comme un
édifice comme un édifice avec des
briques et la culture
ce n'est pas une brique et le mortier
entre les brics et ce qui tient tout ça
ensemble
la culture est partout c'est le reflet
de ce qui se passait dans cette reprise
qui s'amorce
moi c'est ce que je souhaite est
peut-être que c'est long on va voir
encore plus l'essentiel c'est l'art qui
veut nous aider à se sortir de la crise
c'est l'art qui va nous permettre cet
exutoire
cette façon de se rappeler ce qui s'est
passé doit sans jamais oublier d'avoir
des chanteuses qui trouvent des usines à
nous chanter d'aborder des nouveaux
romans des pièces de théâtre pour non
seulement documenté mais nous amener
ailleurs collectivement pour notre santé
mentale collective
oui on a tellement hâte unique n'existe
guère merci beaucoup d'être venus et
merci de m'avoir permis d'en parler au
nom des artistes made vous revoir en
présentiel comme on dit et moi donc et
nous donc avec des sièges pleins on
l'espère merci beaucoup au revoir
une artiste en tout cas qui elle a été
très créative très inspiré par la
pandémie
louis philippe ouimet nous présente
maintenant une danseuse interprète
morgan lethiec qui en a même profité
pour prendre la décision de sa vie
[Musique]
c'est sûr que moi la danse je suis fait
pour ça je me sens bien dans un théâtre
je me sens bien dans mon studio morgan
le tchèque adam c'est presque toute sa
vie depuis qu'elle a enfilé sa première
paire de chaussons à l'âge de 5 ans elle
n'a jamais cessé de perfectionner son
art la fermeture des salles de
spectacles a tout changé
c'est sûr qu'il ya eu un gros choc
émotionnel je pense qu'on est passés par
des hauts et des bas avec des moments de
qu'est-ce que je fais j'arrête tout ça
va durer combien de temps qui ont santé
un petit peu inutile soudainement un peu
rejetés
le choc est survenu après une brillante
carrière
morgan a fait ses premiers pas avec la
la la human steps
pour ensuite se joindre aux ballets jazz
de montréal
à la compagnie marie chouinard et au
cirque du soleil
à 34 ans l'heure est à l'introspection
c'est vrai que pendant cette pandémie
j'ai beaucoup repensé à toutes mes
tournées je peux dire c'est que je suis
allé là je suis allé là même si là ça
s'est arrêté pour moi je pense que j'ai
pas tant un deuil
enfin j'ai enfin j'ai comme un petit
deuil à faire mais c'est pas un deuil
qui est triste et 2 et on ouvre éloigné
de la scène à cause de la pandémie
la danseuse interprète si oui à
l'enseignement second et jo elle à
continuer de rêver et d'être en
mouvement
utilisez les deux bras je reviens j'ai
créé un film de danse cet été c'était
vraiment une nouvelle expérience qui m'a
apporté beaucoup d'autres choses une
nouvelle perspective sur le corps sur
l'image
c'est hyper intéressant quand même pour
moi puis ça me permettait de continuer
dans ces puits de rester vivant en plus
de danser elle a senti le besoin de
communiquer et de créer un balado on se
voyait pu entre danseurs donc c'était le
médium idéal de balados même si j'ai
aucune expérience en journalisme
je me suis juste lancé comme ça si on
essayait de me renouveler aussi moi-même
finalement
mais sa plus grande décision son plus
grand projet n'est pas encore né
[Musique]
dans son ventre
un enfant conçu en raison de la pandémie
donc il ya toujours ce dilemme de quand
est-ce qu'on fait un enfant c'est
tellement important notre carrière on
est tellement passionné que souvent ça
passe avant qu'il a vraiment la pandémie
est arrivé et je pense que c'est sûr que
pour moi ça a énormément fiancée la
prise de décision la maternité est un
sujet presque tabou dans le milieu de la
danse mais peut-être que le temps
d'arrêt pousse à la réflexion hier un
baby boom au niveau de la danse dont je
suis très très heureuse que de ça
la pandémie ça aura permis de s'ouvrir à
ce sujet
en attendant la naissance prévue en juin
est impatiente d'assister à la fin de la
pandémie
morgan a imaginé cette chorégraphie sous
le thème du bretten et de jours
meilleurs à venir
t'imagines mon accouchement comme une
vague ou de loki qui fait cool donc pour
moi c'était c'est presque en main une
préparation à cette naissance
[Musique]
la musique qui accompagne cette
chorégraphie est interprété par le futur
papa
un musicien aussi touché par le
confinement nous ça nous est clairement
inspiré avoir un enfant et on a senti
que c'était tout à converger vers ce la
pandémie aussi le fait que on arrive à
un moment de notre carrière ou sa cité
ça ça vient pas mal ça s'approche de la
dernière chance
côté artistes vous regarde aussi parce
que j'ai assez de stabilité dans ma
carrière que je sais que je peux quand
même me permettre ça est-ce que j'ai
assez de revenus
l'afutt éditeurs la pandémie nous aura
fait vivre le meilleur et le pire
pour morgane lethiec rien ne sera plus
comme avant
si je dois faire un deuil des tournées
je ferai mon deuil puis j'irai peut-être
plus vers l'enseignement
après aussi dans ma tête l'idée de
changement complet de carrière ça c'est
aussi une option qui est très présente
d'ailleurs en ce moment dans le milieu
de la danse
je me laisse quand même flotter parce
qu'on sait pas ce qui va se passer
[Musique]
et nous avons le privilège de les avoir
avec nous voici morgan lethiec et
pierre-alexandre
[Musique]
printemps sors de ta
étrange
dans la plaie
[Musique]
lève ses regards
vers l'est de l'éternel
[Musique]
et le sang
du soleil coup le
l'eau du ciel
[Musique]
je veux seulement
sur l'a6
m
le vent basané
becks ait eu nos poumons
je veux
[Musique]
c'est zéro
les nuages qui passent
coeur qui trop souvent
grandes comme la main
mais en plus mon cerveau
deux saisons salines
ce soit nar
1 ii du
rien de noix
dames 1
[Musique]
ce qui
souffre ou
au chant
vivre
là
k
de l'oise
ou les
je
[Musique]
m ais 2
tout mon corps
[Musique]
c'était morgan lethiec et
pierre-alexandre après la pause comment
la pandémie à bousculer le destin d'une
influence euse en sibérie
[Musique]
la russie est un des pays les plus
touchés par le corps en à virus dans le
monde
le personnel de la santé y travaillent
dans des conditions extrêmement
précaires
surtout dans les régions éloignées où
ils manquent de tout encore aujourd'hui
ce soit notre correspondante à marc
altérer ce coup nous emmène dans la
ville d'irkoutsk en sibérie à 4200 km de
moscou avec l'histoire d'une jeune femme
qui a réussi contre toute attente à
faire bouger les choses pour le mieux
[Musique]
elle ne correspond peut-être pas à
l'idée qu'on se fait de la sibérie une
jeune femme branchée
toujours élégante femme quand il fait
moins 30 degrés ceignac austin a fait
dans la mode et l'auto promotion puis
dezheng accros des réseaux sociaux
elle est une influence assumée qui ne
passe jamais inaperçu quand nous l'avons
accompagné au restaurant ses fils ont
immédiatement reconnu la suivent
religieusement sur instagram depuis le
tout début de la pandémie
c'était elle qui nous a ouvert les yeux
dit christina alors qu'on dise est
encore aux russes de ne pas s'en faire
avec le corps enseignant kostine à a été
un des tout premiers cas connus de kovy
darcos qu'au début du mois d'avril 2020
a fermé sous clef dans une chambre de
peter attaquons tout sur elle à
documenter son expérience en commençant
par l'état lamentable des soins de santé
sénia a continué de raconter sans filtre
le manque de personnel l'absence cruelle
d'équipement des thermomètres au
ventilateur alors que l'état de santé de
sa voisine de chambre
irina se détériorer en direct sous les
yeux de ses cinquante mille abonnés
[Musique]
la marina fut un choc mais aussi un
point tournant de son petit lit de métal
interpeller directement les autorités
une des bulletins de nouvelles ces
appels ont été entendus par le
gouvernent réunion d'urgence
réorganisation des soins et formation du
personnel ont suivi
quand xénia est sorti de l'hôpital mois
plus tard des centaines de ventilateurs
avaient été distribués dans les hôpitaux
de la région d'ica qu'ovide l'a
profondément changé de fashionista
bénévoles la voici en train d'inaugurer
un nouvel appareil à résonance
magnétique que la polyclinique attendait
depuis des années les miens a aussi mis
sur pied sa propre fondation pour venir
en aide à la communauté éprouvés par la
pandémie xing a sauté ce top secret niño
prodigue ses niamey était indispensable
18 yahia colney va une infirmière qui a
attrapé la coved aux soins intensifs une
parfaite inconnue zenia est venu lui
livrer des vivres et l'encourager elle a
su influencer les plus hauts
fonctionnaires dit il ya ici c'est un
exploit youtube de buy in
[Musique]
bien qu'elle soit toujours devant la
caméra à ksenia se sert désormais
d'instagram pour rallier sa communauté
être pas aussi
aujourd'hui elle distribue des jouets
premier aux enfants malades qui n'ont
pas vu leurs parents depuis des semaines
en raison de la colère et elle est
particulièrement fière de son plus
récent projet qu'elle partage avec des
artistes locaux
une murale géante d'une médecin
qui nous avons pu voir juste avant
qu'elle soit installée sur la façade de
l'hôpital là où tout a commencé il ya
une majorité reconnaît les à ceux qui
n'ont pas droit de s'arrêter un symbole
de la force de l'image et des réseaux
sociaux
même là où on s'y attend un antidote
contre l'impuissance qu'on ressent tous
mais pourquoi quand on est confronté aux
épreuves certains rebondissements mieux
que d'autres
j'en ai parlé un peu plus tôt avec le
neuropsychiatre français boris cyrulnik
qui vient de publier des hommes et des
saisons psycho écologie aux éditions
odile jacob
boris cyrulnik qui s'inquiètent après un
an de pandémie pour lui un virage est
indispensable la vie dit il ne pourra
pas reprendre comme avant
vont rester unique merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
c'te plaisir d'être élevé au québec on
vient de vivre une année tellement
particulière vous comment vous traverser
cette période de manière honteusement
agréable taba tant mieux parce que j'ai
la chance de faire partie des
privilégiés qui ont une maison avec un
avec un jardin au bord de la mer et j'en
ai profité pour bien travailler parce
que j'ai été empêchés de voyager
donc j'ai mieux travailler justement
depuis le début notre émission on a vu
des vies qui ont été complètement
bouleversée des changements de carrière
certains réussissent à s'adapter plus
facilement pourquoi certains parmi nous
avant le confinement avaient acquis des
facteurs de protection que c'est à dire
il parlait bien
il avait une famille stable il avait mis
un diplôme suffisant pour avoir un
métier convenable donc il y avait un
grand logement
et quand le virus a imposé le
confinement
ils n'ont pas souffert et après le virus
ils vont redémarrer sans traumatisme
al'inverse ceux qui avant le virus avait
acquis les facteurs de vulnérabilité
famille instable maladie accidents de la
vie surpopulation dans un petit logement
ils vont se retrouver dans trente mètres
carrés avec à six personnes
donc
seul est exaspéré ceux là vont vivre le
confinement comme un traumatisme et
après la sortie du confinement si on les
entoure pas du rap a beaucoup de
processus de résilience peut-être
l'espoir est en train de revenir avec
les vaccins mais en même temps on sent
une très grande fatigue
c'est comme si l'incertitude nous pesait
alors est ce que c'est ça qui cause
notre anxiété parce que parce qu'on sait
pas comment tout ça va se terminer et
quand ça va se terminer
on a une usure de l'âme tout le monde a
un peu marre on voudrait que ce soit
fini
le vaccin va nous donner un plan
d'action dès l'instant où un plan
d'action même si on souffre on affronte
en revanche quand on n'a pas de plan
d'action en 2d part dans tous les sens
donc c'est quoi c'est donc la souffrance
est aggravée par l'incertitude et ça
c'est dangereux pour la sortie du virus
c'est que chaque fois qu'il ya un moment
de chaos social
on constate que les gens qui survivent
dans la certitude soient anxieux parce
qu'ils s'attaquent aux affaires qui
savent pas faire comment se défendre et
que arrive toujours très souvent un
sauveur qui sécurise les gens en leur
disant moi j'ai la solution voté pour
moi et c'est comme ça qu'un grand nombre
de dictateurs sont régulièrement élu
démocratiquement après des périodes de
chaos social
on vous sent un peu inquiet quand même
pour la suite alors eh oui le virus sur
le plan biologique c'est rien c'est 12
gel encapsulé dans une un petit sac de
lipides sais rien tout le reste est un
processus de civilisation s'est créée
par la civilisation dont outreau2
d'élevage d'animaux à manger
déforestation massacre du sol mélangent
des excréments des animaux fabrication
c'est nous qui fabriquons le virus y en
a plein dans la nature de virus mais
c'est nous ensuite il est trop important
d'abord on les a transportés avec les
caravanes de chameaux la route de la
soie
et puis ensuite c'est les avions qui
sont les nouveaux chameaux et qui
transporte les les tissus qui
transportent les aliments avec les
bactéries et avec les virus
les épidémies répéter et vous il va
falloir changer on pourra pas reprendre
notre vie comme elle était avant
alors il ya des gens qui proposent de
reprendre la vie comme elle était avant
il ya même des gens des économistes
surtout qu'ils proposent de rattraper le
retard
donc si on remet en place les processus
qui ont fabriqué le virus et qui l'ont
transporté eh bien on va faire une
nouveau siècle des pestes et dans trois
ans il y aura un nouveau virus avec une
autre formule chimique il faudra tout
recommencer
comment tenir alors avec tout avec
toutes ses mesures sanitaires avec le
couvre-feu notre vie sociale qui est
tellement tellement limité et depuis
maintenant un an que ça dure
à quel point ça aussi c'est compliqué
pour m bien sûr c'est une très grave
le confinement qui qui nous protège du
virus nous agressent nos rôles rythme
ans est psychologiquement isolement
sensoriel provoque des altérations
cérébrales
le bébé même s'il est un peu altérée si
sa mère est sécurisé elle deviendra
sécurisante pour le bébé qu'elle porte
dans son ventre ou dans ses bras si les
personnes âgées sont isolés c'est très
grave
là une personne âgée en isolement
sensoriel
elle se laisse partir on appelle ça le
syndrome du glissement elle fesses de
manger laisse deux mois et elle meurt
n'ont pas de déshydratation mais de
carences affectives parce qu'elle se
laisse partir et la partie dangereuse de
la population c'est les adolescents les
adolescents sont une période sensible de
leur développement
c'est le moment où ils prennent leur
trajectoire affective c'est le moment
des grandes rencontres
il ya déjà un an perdu quand il vient
déjà beaucoup de décrochages quand ils
vont faire pour se relancer certains
bien sûr pour se relancer ce qui avait
un bon entourage mais beaucoup vont
casser et parler des personnes âgées
justement elles ont payé un prix très
lourd dans cette pandémie
alors pour elle est-ce que les séquelles
vont être durable le cerveau des
personnes âgées beaucoup moins plastique
que celui des jeunes les personnes âgées
n'ont plus la même forme de résine
c'est à dire que pour se remettre à
vivre il leur suffit de peu un coup de
téléphone de temps en temps est visible
de 15 points et la possibilité de vivre
dans leur mémoire avec des photos donc
le processus de résilience sera facile
parce que les personnes âgées au moins
de deux bornes mois d'exigeant mais si
on fêtera ça ira beaucoup morts beaucoup
de familles ont pas pu accompagner leur
prochain dans les derniers jours pendant
la première vague ou même faire des
rituels de deuil ça aussi c'est un
traumatisme en ans alors c'est un
traumatisme pour les enfants pour les
survivants ça c'est la culpabilité
pathologique que beaucoup de gens ont
déjà je n'ai rien fait je le même pas
dire adieu il est mort mon père tout
seul et alors quand c'est très embêtant
parce que toutes les cultures ont
inventé des rituels du deuil apple seule
culture sans rituel du deuil et ses
rituels du deuil confie sa respecter le
mort et à redonner leur dignité aux
vivants que j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait
je lui ai dit à dieu j'ai fait ce qu'il
fallait et là c'est pas possible se
culpabiliser auto agressent et très
souvent ils ont des comportements des
chèques
une dernière question pour vous mais
elle est là je sais pas si on peut
répondre comme ça mais monsieur serene
comment donner un sens à tout ce qui
nous est arrivé
c'est la question fondamentale c'est que
si on donne sens à ce qui nous arrive on
supporte rang ce qui nous arrive et si
on ne donne pas sauf on va déprimer
parce que c'est un être une souffrance
absurde
alors question d'un sens si on se dit
d'accord on a ruiné notre pays d'accord
on a perdu un an
d'accord on s'est beaucoup ennuyé mais
en échange on va mettre en place une
manière de vivre ensemble qui sera plus
belle et plus harmonieuse donc ça valait
la peine de souffrir et à ce moment là
notre souffrance prend sens ça valait la
peine de souffrir parce que après on va
déclencher un processus de résilience
affectives culturelles et on vivra mieux
ça valait la peine de souffrir
j'espère qu'on dira cette phrase dans
quelques mois on l'espère tous monsieur
sérénac merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation c'est un plaisir de
vous parler c'est un plaisir de parler
avec vous en tout cas ils ont su
profiter de la pandémie après la pause
quelle est la recette ensoleillée du
groupe sts et aux masses
[Musique]
salut tout le monde
moi c'est andré j'ai 19 ans je vous
parle de ma prison moderne cabinet ma
belle qu'à mon bel espace de travail
sont l'université aller à poser la
pandémie je suis des cours
universitaires baning de chez moi d'être
à l'université du nord de la commune
italie aux études postsecondaires de
scooter mais j'avais trouvé un cours en
musique et qui m'intéressait beaucoup
par l'amélioration nouveau brunswick
elle mais le constat de l'atlantique à
famille c'était possible de farid jeunes
helvètes n'ont pas eu la chance de
demeurer chez à ottawa pour l'université
car tous les cours sont alignés c'est
plus sécuritaire de rester à la maison
et j'ai décidé de recommencer
en quoi et par ici au nouveau réduit
même domaine par domaine qui m'intéresse
au mois de septembre j'étais assez
d'aller à toronto et étudié à
l'université de ryerson
mais à cause de pandémie j'ai décidé de
rester chez moi étudient dans le confort
de ma maison et ça me permet de vivre
des opportunités uniques quand même
comme sculpter des belles sculptures au
festival du voyageur avec le temps que
j'avais j'ai aussi fait un peu d'art je
perds mon casque de vélo avec la
silhouette de vancouver avec les photos
que j'appris mais j'ai commencé à faire
des câlins
j'étais également chance et faire des
essais pour l'équipe d'athlétisme droit
mais tous les sports ont été annulés
dont quelques villes est vraiment
bénéfique
salut voici pedro mello je suis un
joueur de foot de gatineau j'ai vraiment
les arts sont freinées par la pandémie
parce que oui je pense que l'autre km je
suis ici à vieillir en utah et enfin la
sortie de tous est plus important que la
vie continue
oui des étudiants qui persévèrent malgré
les difficultés boris cyrulnik nous
disait avant la pause
les jeunes sont parmi les plus grandes
victimes de la pandémie un âge critique
de leur développement
mais voici un autre bel exemple
d'adaptation
notre correspondant yannick dumont baron
nous emmène sur les toits de barcelone à
la rencontre du groupe sts et au mas on
y va la recette est toute simple
trois musiciens une terrasse ensoleillée
et un peu d'imagination
[Rires]
high class et guilhem non pas 30 ans ils
sont amis et colloques confinés ensemble
au printemps dernier avec légèreté
ce terme évoque le mot d'ordre quasi
universelle du printemps dernier rester
à la maison
[Musique]
beau temps mauvais temps les colocs
improvise en s'inspirant de cette drôle
de période
il utilise les instruments qui leur
tombe sous la main enregistre avec leur
téléphone
[Musique]
rapidement d'autres artistes collaborent
à distance dont manu chao
[Musique]
des chansons courtes et simples qui
touche beaucoup de jeu il s'agit à
l'autre bout du monde justement le
canadien michael bublé cherche à savoir
qui sont ces trois jeunes qui l'ont fait
sourire que voulait il
le trio permettent aux canadiens
d'enregistrer sa propre version de leur
sixième chanson
[Musique]
au hockey
bagad bébé sur l'actuelle campagne
[Musique]
notoriété de michael bublé gonflent les
rangs des admirateurs d'ester romas
quelques semaines plus tard son et
musique les contacts un disque est
enregistré une tournée en europe et en
amérique latine est prévue cette année
[Musique]
comme mon frigo je n'ai pas ça il répète
mais ça n'est pas ça la d2 comores mais
c'est grâce à l'adaptation fils est un
ingénieur de chez eux comme ce rôle
notre avis est finie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
formidable une histoire qui fait du bien
surtout en cette période
alors on arrive à la fin de l'émission
que faut-il retenir de cette année qu'on
vient de vivre
est ce qu'on peut trouver un sens dans
tout ça on a commencé à en parler avec
boris cyrulnik mais je retrouve
maintenant avec grand plaisir
mes collègues alain crevier l'animateur
bonsoir alain ça fait plaisir de vous et
l'animateur maintenant de ce très beau
balado être sur notre application audio
et charles tisseyre l'animateur bien sûr
de découverte bonsoir charge voire sedin
un plaisir de vous avoir ici alors on a
commencé avec vos chars le côté
scientifique est ce qu'on a appris qu
est-ce qu on tire comme leçon de tout ce
qu'on a vécu depuis un an mais je pense
que la principale chose c'est de se dire
que la pandémie qu'on est en train de
vivre était prévu par les experts depuis
longtemps on s'y attendait on n'y ont
pas été surpris de voir arriver et ça
nous amène à nous dire qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire pour éviter la prochaine
parce que en amont on n'a pas réglé les
problèmes et les problèmes c'est quoi si
nous en août surtout qu'ils somment la
source du problème
les activités humaines on rentre dans la
nature sauvage on change les habitants
les détruirons en cause une érosion des
écosystèmes partout à travers le monde
il ya des espèces animales qui sont en
train de s'effondrer littéralement mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire quand on
investit dans nature sauvage comme ça
c'est que on va quelque part où on ne
devrait pas se retrouver en grand nombre
ont construit une route on construit une
mine ont fait de la déforestation pour
pour avoir des terres d'élevage qui
n'étaient pas là avant mais quand on
fait ça on modifie complètement les
écosystèmes
on modifie des habitats et on rentre en
contact avec la nature sauvage avec les
animaux sauvages avec la faune sauvage
qui selon me remettre des malades y est
en fait son porteur de toutes sortes de
virus des milliers de virus et ils sont
en équilibre avec ces virus l'appui sont
au fond séparer de nous mais à
l'interface à l'endroit au fond on les
rencontre avec nos fermes avec nos
habitations près par exemple des chauves
souris meurent faute des chauves souris
sur les laisser tranquilles n'y aurait
pas de problème
les chauffe des chauves souris sont près
de nous maintenant et elles sont
porteuses de beaucoup de virus alors le
fait de deux d'agir comme ça sans
réfléchir comme si nous étions des
maîtres de gaia de cette biosphère
comme si nous appartenait comme si on
pouvait faire n'importe quoi mais en
fait on dévore l'environnement autour de
nous et ce faisant et bien on se rend
vulnérable face à toutes ces maladies
qui sont porteuses par ce passé par ces
animaux donc des leçons à tirer de ce
côté là voilà du côté de notre condition
humaine nous pauvres mortels
merci beaucoup de choses énormément et
non mes marques je pense que certains
diront c'est un week-end comme mais je
faire du pouce sur ce que tu dis ça
parce que dans le fond on a vécu pendant
des siècles et des siècles et des
siècles avec une religion qui nous a dit
quoi que le mot n'avait été fait pour
nous que nous étions car du monde et que
tout ça c'était à nous à coloniser à le
prendre à la fin malheureusement on a
comme développé au fil du temps et
peut-être parce que la science nous a
aidés aussi le sentiment qu'on était
qu'on était qu'on allait durer très très
longtemps qu'on était les maîtres du
monde il philosophe français andré comte
sponville qui au printemps dernier me
dit mais j'ai un scoop pour vous
monsieur crevier acheter intéressé
venant d'andré comte-sponville et il me
dit il on va tous mourir
ah bon ça peut être un peu brutale gère
200 prévenus de la première vague mais
dans le fond ça ressemble à quoi cette
histoire là on a gagné en espérance de
vie sans cesse un mois par ci deux mois
par là à bout de tout ça on est rendus
où on est en train de fantasmer sur
l'idée d'une espérance de vie pourrait
être centenaire
et si on réussissait juste à ralentir le
processus de vieillissement naturel
peut-être qu'on fera près le sens
15 il ya des gens sérieux qui qui
fantasme sur ce qu'est ce qui vient de
se passer un petit virus de rien du tout
qui avait même pas l'intention de faire
du tort nous a ramenés à l'homme nous
sommes je suis désolé de vous taire mais
nous sommes mortels et nous sommes
mortels pour longtemps alors c'est comme
ça il y en a un qui militent et c'est ça
que j'allais dire c'est une méga dose
d'humilité dans les grandes heures qu'on
pouvait se donner dans le contrôle et
dans la possession du monde et de notre
avenir à nous il ya quelque chose là les
quelque chose là charles ce qu'on
retient aussi de toute cette période
c'est que les santé publique des pays
occidentaux de beaucoup de pays
industrialisés ont réagi très lentement
à cette pandémie en fait oui d'ailleurs
on a regardé ça mes collègues et moi
découverte on a fait une émission là
dessus sur les stratégies de lutte
on a rencontré une vingtaine d'experts
et on leur a demandé qu'elles sont quels
ont été les meilleures stratégies de
lutte et et les pires et c'est clair que
les meilleurs c'est les pays qui ont agi
très rapidement par exemple la corée du
sud a développé un test de dépistage
tout de suite là avant même d'avoir des
cas alors il fallait au fond aussi fermé
les frontières contrôler sévèrement les
frontières les pays qui ont fait ça
comme l'australie la nouvelle zélande
or aujourd'hui se retrouve dans une
situation presque normale enfin les deux
co vite 0170 cornes
ben oui outrés ou ou très peu d'idées
étant que si tu fermes qui frontières tu
laisse peu de virus rentrée et les virus
qui rentrait tout ce que tu fais c'est
puisque tu testes rapidement les gens
que tu les traces et que tu es jeune les
gens qui sont malades tu gardes le
contrôle sur l'épidémie le problème
c'est que dans les pays occidentaux les
pays industrielisés beaucoup d'entre eux
dont le canada et les pays européens on
a été très lent à réagir et finalement
corps l'organisation mondiale de la
santé qui a été lente à réagir aussi à
déclarer la pandémie ya un an c'était
déjà trop tard
c'était on était déjà dans une situation
où le virus se baladait on avait perdu
le contrôle au fond de ce virus là est
la seule façon au fond de rade d'essayer
de reprendre le contrôle ça a été le
confinement une arme de 2,2 sinon si
l'on veut de la prévention massive mais
avec des conséquences psychosociales
très importante qu'on a connu on utilise
cette arme là si on a perdu le contrôle
mais la meilleure stratégie c'est de ne
pas perdre le contrôle c'est d'agir
rapidement et de circonscrire au fond
l'infection et la propagation pour
éradiquer le virus nous on mitigé
c'était une une stratégie de mitigation
pour aplatir la courbe ça fonctionne et
oui dans une certaine mesure pour
protéger le système hospitalier autant
que possible mais on n'a pas repris le
contrôle
et l'été dernier quand dans le fond tout
s'est calmé c'est là qu'on a perdu trois
mois c'est là qu'on aurait dû justement
mettre sur place
mettre en place un système de 2,2 pour
tester en grand nombre en galice gens
pour le faire
tracer les gens pour que à l'automne
quand la preuve la deuxième vague a
recommencé on aurait été prêt alors si
tout ça au fond qui est en train d'être
revus en ce moment et au canada on se
pose beaucoup de questions sur la façon
dont les choses ont progressé
les quatre provinces de l'atlantique
sont notre succès story et s'est
observée à travers le monde cette bulle
de l'atlantique m'a formidablement
fonctionner ils ont fermé grosso modo la
frontière ils ont testé est tracé et est
aujourd'hui dans le fond ce sont les
provinces qui s'en sont le mieux tirés
nous avait parlé de la mort alain ya
aussi le vieillissement dont on veut
parler parce que là aussi j'ai passé un
10 drame épouvantable dans les sièges et
célian on a parlé toute subvention
fallait dans le fond là on dit moi je
pense à mon père et à ma mère alors
c'est la deuxième guerre c'était leur
moment c'était le moment de mon père ma
mère c'était ça mon grand père c'était
la première et la deuxième il y en a qui
diront que le moment du récent seller le
11 septembre 2001 mais moi ce candidat
c'est à l'échelle de la planète et c'est
notre moment
et qu'est ce qui se dégage de sa cellule
une vulnérabilité qu'on a on n'aurait
pas passé possible l'image qui me vient
en tête quand je dis vulnérables et je
ne peux pas je pourrais jamais le disent
aussi que je pense que je suis pas tout
seul c'est de voir des gars et des
filles de l'armée canadienne qui en en
os 6 h et celle d'esso cupidon vieux on
a appelé l'armée pour faire un job qui
ne les concerne pas c'était à nous de le
faire lors c'est pas seulement moi je
dirais c'est un constat un cuisant
constat d'échec
d'une société qui a eu l'impression
qu'elle avait le contrôle surtout
qu'elle était au dessus de tout et qui
avait oublié que des gens qu'on aime
tout à coup on les a privés même de
leurs plus proches de leur parenté leur
enfant au moment où israël où il allait
mourir leur nom il ya pour moi il ya
quelque chose là qui relève de la
vulnérabilité
mais c'est pas la seule chose qui a été
impacté par s convient dit je m'en veux
parce que tu m'aimes là la liberté je
pense qu'on perçoit maintenant les
libertins peu différemment si j'avais
dit on a que votre fils est votre fille
dans le sous sol d'un ami allait
recevoir la visite de la police 1500
dollars d'amendé chacun vous avez du
monde et foule ici j'avais du couvre-feu
à compter de 20h puis si vous êtes dans
la rue jamais plus on n'avait pas pensé
ça et curieusement aujourd'hui on a
massivement accepter ces mesures là
qu'on a compris c'est des mesures
sanitaires
on a combats à mener mais notre
perception tu t'écoutes la liberté vient
de charger on ne voit plus la liberté de
la même manière et je pense que c'est
peut-être tant mieux parce que cette
liberté
on a accepté d'en laisser tomber des
morceaux pour le bien commun pour lui
pour l'ensemble de la population parce
qu'honnêtement je pense qu'on a en tête
ce qu'on a laissé faire avec les
personnes âgées
une dernière chose je pense que c'est
crucial parce que on a tellement parlé
des personnes âgées pendant cette
pandémie mais toujours à partir des ch
et celle des ou à peu près or la
population des vieux c'est à dire 25 65
ans et plus d'aquarelles 16 7% de la
population des années qu'ils sont dans
une situation chcd ça veut dire qu'une
vaste majorité de personnes âgées qui ne
sont pas dans cette situation là
peut-être qu'on a une longue réflexion à
faire sur ce que c'est que vieillir ce
que c'est que mourir notre liberté
puis les années qui sont hostiles je
pense qu'on a littéralement oublié on
pense que ils sont tous dans un siège
c'est celle d abandonner en manque
d'harmonie cas et on aurait pu les
consulter un peu plus ces personnes
d'âgés sur ce qu'elle sur le risque ça
resemble oui c'est sûr là je pense qu'on
a une longue réflexion à faire alors il
nous reste quelques secondes le monde
d'après
il va être comment rapidement à charge
mais maintenant on a des vaccins on sait
comment faire des vaccins rapidement en
étant seul safran beaucoup d'argent pour
les faire mais qu'on peut lui faire
trouver peut les faires plan d'affaires
nouveau que le gouvernement américain a
lancé de financer des compagnies en
amont pour qu'elles ne prennent pas de
risques financiers qu'ils commencent à
produire leurs accès tout de suite avant
même de savoir s'il va fonctionner ça
c'est une des recettes qui a vraiment
bien fonctionné puis on essaie de
développer un vaccin à universelle qui
pourraient nous protéger contre tous les
coronavirus y compris ceux évidemment
qui pourrait très bien arriver dans
quelques années ça c'est le saint graal
il ya plusieurs équipes qui travaillent
là dessus et elle avance ça c'est
l'espoir
actuellement après bah oui c'est ça moi
je pense au moment où le premier minis
du québec et ça c'est partout ailleurs
dans le monde nous a dit on mais le
québec se repose dans mon salon je me
suis dit c'est pas possible ça se fait
pas on peut pas faire ça il va y avoir
un déficit énorme
la dette publique va exploser les
entreprises ont fait faillite mais
enfants vous perdre leur job et pourquoi
je disais ça c'est parce que ça fait des
décennies qu'on nous dit l'économie
c'est une machine qu'on ne peut pas
arrêter et je reconnais un entrepreneur
quand même ses labos québec robert
dutton qui m'a dit m'a dit moi je pense
que le fait qu'on ait arrêté l'économie
c'est tout l'espoir de l'humanité là
dedans on vient de prioriser la vie
humaine à l'économie moi je trouve qu'il
ya quelque chose là qui ouvre des
perspectives sur l'avenir on ne pourra
plus dire en tout cas on ne pouvait pas
on ne pourra que dire on n'a pas voulu
et on espère qu'on saura quoi faire avec
surtout avec une crise climatique qui
sont alors charles merci beaucoup vous
continuez nous éclairer a découvertes
sur cette pandémie
à la ville on suit votre balade aux
lettres et aussi vous avez une émission
résilience la semaine prochaine quand je
regardais beaucoup à vous deux
alors voila merci aussi à tous nos
invités à nos journalistes merci à vous
à la maison d'avoir été là on se
souhaite à tous bon courage pour la
suite
bonsoir à bientôt on se laisse sur la
musique de ce terreau masse
magali pêcheurs les teen choice cabinet
soit mortel à gaby pêche
le team plus comme si des choix la star
ac' albi challenger discovery bay chat
[Musique]